santiago como lo dices y como lo hace
remarcado durante toda la jornada por
supuesto las negociaciones del preside
han sido conflictivas desde todo punto
de vista y además son únicas porque el
reino unido es el primer país que deja
esta comunidad así que todo lo que pase
de aquí en adelante pues habrá que
observarlo con mucha minucia porque como
dices el acuerdo está firmado pero hay
muchos puntos todavía por negociar como
de último minuto también fue como dices
el acuerdo entre el gobierno español y
el gobierno británico para que gibraltar
es una territorio británico ultramar no
se convierta en una frontera exterior de
la unión europea eso que significa que
gibraltar se convertirá entrará en la
zona schengen que hace parte de los 26
países de la unión europea de los 27
países así que entonces se unirá a esta
comunidad quienes viajen desde españa a
gibraltar no necesitarán pasaporte pero
si los británicos que vayan desde este
país hacia esa zona entonces tendrán que
su documento de identidad para poder
ingresar al país se ha hablado de que se
revisara este principio de acuerdo cada
cuatro años es así que es un punto bien
importante santiago pero también por
ejemplo en el caso del nuevo sistema
migratorio que el reino unido- estrenará
a partir de mañana para los ciudadanos
europeos porque se acaba la libre
circulación de ciudadanos es decir
quienes quieran venir a trabajar o
estudiar ciudadanos europeos por
supuesto a este país deben someterse a
un sistema migratorio de puntos que
demostrar por ejemplo que hablan inglés
que tienen calificaciones para poder
apostar a un trabajo aquí y hasta que
tienen un contrato laboral en el caso de
los británicos que viven o quieren hacer
lo mismo trabajar o vivir en otros
países europeos tendrán entonces que
someterse a las reglas migratorias que
imponga cada país porque santiago por
supuesto sobre todo cuando se pueda
viajar en las épocas del invierno muchos
británicos quieren ir a países del
mediterráneo como italia grecia españa
seguramente limitaciones de movilidad
luisa que afectan quizás maquinada a los
sectores más jóvenes
ha sido en verdad
por supuesto recuerdo en el 2016 cuando
se votó el referendo para salir de la
unión europea la población más golpeada
eran los jóvenes porque veían en esto en
la libre circulación de ciudadanos una
oportunidad para aprender idiomas para
transformar su vida así que fue un golpe
para ellos y también porque el reino
unido- saliendo de la unión europea se
retira del programa erasmus para hacer
intercambio universitario entre ciudad
entre universidades europeas pero este
país el reino unido lanzó un programa
especial similar en el que se puede
hacer esto pero con todas las
universidades del mundo así que los
jóvenes han sentido como ese impacto
también por las vacaciones es bien
interesante santiago como en estos días
en que estamos que la noticia más
importante que ocupan nuestras vidas es
la situación con con el coronavirus pero
cuando se pueda volver a viajar entonces
el impacto para la mayoría de la
población se notará por supuesto porque
porque todo se transformará para los
viajeros británicos y los europeos entre
aeropuerto
por el solo hecho de dónde van a hacer
fila en los aeropuertos británicos los
europeos
entran como ciudadanos británicos y
viceversa en los aeropuertos europeos
ahora no si un europeo viene a este país
tiene que hacer fila como las dos otras
nacionalidades los viajeros de otras
nacionalidades también sea el gobierno
ha pedido a los viajeros que vayan a
europa que entonces su sistema de
telefonía puede tener incluso un cobro
adicional porque el roaming puede
empezar a ser cobrado eso es algo que no
pasa en este momento y también les han
dicho el gobierno a los viajeros que lo
mejor es que contraten un seguro de
viajes así que todos estos impactos se
van a ir sintiendo poco a poco porque la
noticia del coronavirus es tan compleja
que la gente no puede salir y parte de
lo que va a empezar a notarse por
supuesto es con las vacaciones con los
alimentos habrá entonces incremento de
los precios porque más del 50% de los
alimentos frescos que se consume en el
reino unido- provienen de países como
italia como españa
como grecia así que habrá que ver qué va
a suceder finalmente yo